PlayStation Plus is changing the most
unloved tier of ps+ premium and Deluxe
today received an upgrade thanks to the
Sony pictures core app this has nothing
to do with video games it's the place
Sony wants us to buy and rent movies
from when we're on our PlayStation and
as of today ps+ premium and Deluxe
subscribers can access a bunch of those
movies free of charge this isn't the
most impressive selection of movies but
there are some absolute bangers in here
and the selection will constantly update
too I'd love to know your thoughts does
this addition do anything for you movies
on a game subscription and remember
mobious is a Sony movie It's morbin Time